so is Lamar better or is he really still
struggling well he's been released from
the hospital he's it's so crazy he was
literally he regrets was not talking he
couldn't walk any of that were you
shocked that he was taking herbal viagra
overdosing on herbal viagra were you
laughing at that yeah I mean I don't
think that's what he overdosed on I
think he I don't know why they're making
that such a strong point I'm making it a
strong point that's mind-blowing to me
he's young guy what does he need herbal
viagra cuz I think when you're doing so
many other things you're a little limp
down there I said listen you do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do but please
promise me you'll never go back to a
disgusting brothel again I go and if you
want to pay someone you could pay
someone that in the privacy of your
hotel like what are you doing one day I
came in and he was like googling Lamar
Odom overdose he saw like surveillance
footage or whatever online he was
watching a video and eyelid grabbed the
iPad I said what the [ __ ] are you doing
I've been trying to protect you I don't
want this to hurt you and I have to
remember he has no idea what people know
he doesn't know if we only found him and
this is private like he doesn't know he
hasn't seen any TV reports anything no
I've kept things very because I'm no
kidding
nothing so who does he rely on you right
it sounds like you're running the show I
never wanted to stop it of course not
but I've always feared this would happen
I mean that's what prompted our divorce
right he's gonna make a play for you I'm
telling you he's gonna want you back
he's probably formal emotional
attachment you were there for him all
the time I'm telling you that I love
Lamar obviously I wouldn't be doing this
if I didn't he has so much that he has
to prove to himself right first tone to
lay low on the [ __ ] I mean one girl two
girls okay twenty girl well I talked to
him about brothels all I say uh-huh
you're not in there anymore girls will
do this for free
yeah even admit that he says yeah I know
yeah it's crazy I guess he's not looking
for deep love he's just looking for the
sex you know what I mean hey still have
it no cheese